virginia roberts affray has been
fighting to be heard for years now
her new york court appearance has
renewed focus on her allegation that
Jeffrey Epstein made her have sex with
Prince Andrew when she was 17 years old
you can't say he didn't know her
he can't say he wasn't friendly with her
I think it's hard to look at that
picture and say that you had no idea
that she was young
Virginia Roberts Jeff Ray's lawyer says
Prince Andrew has so far refused their
request for an interview if he would sit
down and talk to us and let everything
come out and as as our client said
yesterday just come clean this is the
time to do it you know continuing to
delay and obfuscate I don't think really
is in his interest because this is not
going away there's too much evidence
here for the allegations simply to go
away
Prince Andrew was seen inside Epstein's
New York mansion in 2010 this video
obtained by the Mail on Sunday there is
the picture you mentioned there is also
Prince Andrew in 2010 waving from inside
the door of Jeffery Epstein's mansion
what do we take from that if anything
well I think that is simply another
illustration of the fact that Prince
Andrew and Jeffrey Epstein were very
close he was at the mansion he was very
comfortable he knew that there were
young women coming and going the
testimony of people who were at the
mansion is that nobody could be at that
mansion and not understand that Jeffrey
Epstein had a number of unusual
relationships with young women in a
statement Prince Andrew said I met mr.
Epstein in 1999 during the time I knew
him I saw him infrequently and probably
no more than only once or twice a year I
have stayed in a number of his
residences
no stage during the limited time I spent
with him did I see witness or suspect
any behavior of the sort that
subsequently led to his arrest and
conviction I deplore the exploitation of
any human being and would not condone
participating or encourage any such
behavior Prince Andrew's nationality and
royal status make this a complex legal
situation Miss Roberts rephrase team are
exploring options to compel him to speak
it's clear that for her this isn't over
Amanda Walker Sky News New York